cet écran est quasiment incassable en
fait c'est pas réellement cet écran
c'est une protection d'écran qu'on vient
mettre par score c'est une techno que je
viens de voir ici au MWC à Barcelone
alors je vous lis ce n'est pas du tout
une vidéo qui est sponsorisée pas du
tout pas du tout pas du tout mais est-ce
que ça montre au travers de cette démo
c'est qu'on arrive aujourd'hui à vous
proposer des protections d'écran où on
peut y aller avec de la masse on peut y
aller avec un cutter on peut faire pas
mal de choses c'est extrêmement
résistant d'où l'intérêt de venir
protéger votre smartphone alors vous en
conviendrez la démo reste bluffante pour
autant ne vous amusez pas à reproduire
ça chez vous qui est intéressant ce que
vous dit le fabricant ici c'est qu'ils
viennent intégrer quatre couches il y a
du vert mais va rester de colle qui
permet d'avoir une répartition très
facile une installation très facile et
puis il nous montre également lorsqu'il
viennent après le casser et bien lorsque
vous allez toucher avec votre doigt vous
risquez pas de vous blesser donc voilà
on voit de plus que les techno évoluent
même au niveau des protections d'écran
et je trouve ça une fois de plus
extrêmement bluffant je passe ça vous
intéresse que ça vous est déjà arrivé de
faire tomber votre smartphone de casser
de casser les 30 vos smartphones et de
vous être 10 jours là mince si j'avais
su et bien j'aurais mis une protection
adaptée marquez moi ça bien évidemment
dans les commentaires